today I'm here at Costco to show you
some really interesting foods with some
nutrition with my friend Bobby who
happens to just be around and I just
grabbed him off the street and we are
going to go through and analyze certain
foods and just look at the nutrition
content and you're going to also help me
out as well let's do it so Bobby I have
a question uh what's wrong with this
picture it says vegetable oil because
they're not using any of those
vegetables to make the I mean this is
seed oils this is where you have all of
the stuff the omega-6 fatty acids this
is inflammatory and how can they keep
this in this clear uh container um it's
very unstable oil it's totally oxidized
and so you put this into your body it
kind of gets latched it leeches into the
membranes it stays in there for a long
period of time I think the shelf life is
what two years yeah and what does that
made I didn't see the ingredients but I
guarantee it'll say canola or sunflower
oil or soybean oil 100% soybean oil so
that's your vegetables yeah right I mean
I there's a lot of soybean oil to make
this so it's just unnatural so don't use
this one okay what about this one o this
one actually this one kind of pisses me
off cuz it has the hard healthy seal on
there isn't that crazy oh my goodness
how can they do that yeah this is U all
GMO yeah yeah it's literally rancid oil
in a jug for
you maybe lubricate my my tires I
wouldn't even do that to my car to be
honest no you're right exactly so you
got the canola oil right here can you
explain what high oleic sunflower
there's a type of fat called oleic and
um it's a little bit healthier but we
still got the oxidation because it's an
unsaturated fat so it goes bad with
light heat oxygen so how do they keep it
like this preservatives and they cook it
I think they go through like four
different cycles and when they process
this they use pressure they use uh
deodorizers is that crazy they literally
turn it rancid to make it and then have
to deod Miz it to make it palatable yeah
crazy yeah it's you know here's the last
thing I want to say about this and so if
you look at the trends of sugar obesity
the actually sugars are kind of going
down what's going always parallels this
graph is these seed oils okay so I think
these are at the core of insulin
resistance obesity maybe even a little
bit more than sugars wow interesting
grape seed oil same thing same thing
same thing it's a seed oil you know how
grape seed oil came into existence as
many years ago the wine makers were
wondering what to do with the seeds
after they pressed it it's a waste
product and they figured let's turn it
into oil but we have to deodorize it and
high pressure it and turn it into a
garbage seed oil incredible I guess if
we keep going this way we start getting
some olive oils avocado oil oh avocado
oil there we go better much better um I
like to step it up to Extra Virgin Olive
Oil but of course there's a better one
right here right so if you're going to
Costco this is a really good one you
tell us why for sure so over 80% of the
extra-virgin olive oil on the store
shelf is fake it either has cut with
seed oils it's made with rancid olives
or doesn't qualify to meet the extra
virgin standards this bottle the 100%
Italian extra Virg olive oil is lab
certified to be pure really high quality
at a great price and it's single origin
because look at the back of your olive
oil not the one you have at home and the
big jug from Straight From Italy this
one right here is like many Olive oils
if you look at the back it'll always
have a key to tell you where it comes
from and this one comes from four
different countries Argentina Spain
Greece and Chile how do you have
traceability when you have olives from
four different countries processed in
another country which is why you want
single origin like that one so I want to
talk about pumpkin seeds Okay get the
one with the sea salt check this out
magnesium really good source of
magnesium and just a fourth of a cup
that's 40% so if you just did like a
little more than
like two servings of this you're going
to get your daily supply of magnesium
which is really important for sleeping
reducing cortisol stress your muscles
and energy making energy as well plus it
has manganese which is another Trace
mineral for your mitochondria to give
you detoxifying ability uh getting rid
of poisons and uh just General Health so
this is a an awesome product I think
bonus points for this also is the
sprouting cuz when you sprout a seed yes
more nutrition you get rid of the uh
antinutrients actins go away but read
the ingredients because what happens if
we pick up something else there oh yeah
check this up show people what's in here
yeah so this is an Omega mix here so
it's an anti-inflammatory mix but it's
coated in sunflower oil sugar and canola
oil that's the trif factor of
inflammation that is inflammation when
they talk about the Omega they're
talking about the walnuts and it's the
precursor ala that turns into the active
form you're not going to do a lot of
conversion it's not really the active
form of the omega-3 so this is going to
create inflammation another bonus also
since we're in cold and flu season this
did have a bunch of zinc which is really
good for your immune system too so these
are a nutrient powerhouses absolutely so
I'm going to tell you about a little gem
this is raw organic sauerkraut okay the
key is raw don't get the stuff in the
bottle that's pasteurized you want the
raw stuff why because when you heat it
you kill off the key things this is one
of the best probiotics that you can take
and that has the most vitamin C out of
anything one cup is 700 milligrams
vitamin C that's seven that's 10 times
your rdas for vitamin C which is good
for collagen plus uh this cabbage is
filled with glutamine which is great for
gut health helping your microb the
lining if you have leaky gut this is
something you probably could tolerate if
you have acid reflux gastritis you might
tolerate this so it's so really it's a
probiotic it's fermented it has vitamin
C like nobody's business I don't know
yeah it's a Powerhouse and the price I
was just telling Dr Berg at most stores
half the size of wild brine is $8 you
get a massive jug for $9.59 I eat it
almost every day Pro tip when you're
done don't throw it away the juice in
there you just do shots of it it's
basically like um dairyfree cafir this
is so good for your gut along with the
inflammation
holy cow yeah it's it's literally one of
the healthiest things that I recommend
as a part of your you know it doesn't
have a lot of protein but it has a lot
of other things that you do need yeah
this was gone the last month and it was
the worst month of my life it's back now
happy days so I want to mention this
very important uh ingredient in
mayonnaise okay and this is soy oil you
don't want to get one with soy oil you
want to get something like this okay
from chosen with 100% avocado oil and
avocado oil is very very unique because
it's not a seed oil it's very similar to
um olive oil and so and you just want to
make sure you read the label and there's
no additional seed oils because we're
trying to lower your inflammation by
getting rid of the omega-6 fatty acids
and this is a really good substitute for
something like this the nice thing about
buying it a Costco Dr Burg is the price
so it's 24 cents an ounce it's literally
double the price at most grocery stores
and besides being a anti-inflammatory
oil avocado oil you have to worry about
where it comes from chosen foods like
Primal kitchen does 100% Mexican H
avocado oil so it's super high quality
it's not oxidized or anything like that
and then yes this has the soybean oil he
talked about but why would you also want
sugar natural flavorings which I call
the biggest lie in the grocery store and
a preservative that masks rancidity
called calcium disodium Eda that's so
true yes so true absolutely so if you
have a choice between the extra virgin
olive oil wild Pacific sardin or just
sardines and olive oil get the extra
virgin it's just a little bit better a
little bit cleaner but let me tell you
the benefit of these wild pafic sardines
you have amazing selenium you have DHA
DHA is anti-inflammatory it's like a
omega-3 fatty acid to offset all the
other omega-6 that we're exposed to but
the big thing is selenium selenium is
awesome for your thyroid especially if
you have something like Hashimoto it's
good to build up glutathione which is
good for your liver so it's a good
natural antio o in general very cool and
the cool thing is both are good oils but
a lot of canned fishes will have seed
oils in there so you have to read the
ingredients and Dr bur's correct you
want the Evo because how you get extra
virgin olive oil into olive oil is by a
little more processing not terrible but
every time you do process you do oxidize
the oil and create more inflammation so
Evo for the wi okay I want to talk about
a one a day okay if you look at these
one a days and you look at the first
ingredient what does that say Bobby that
says calcium carbonate okay that's
called Limestone you'd be better off
chewing on the cement outside on the
building because feel how heavy that is
it's like a great for a paper weight
anything that's the first ingredient is
the majority of the product so you're
dealing with you know the worst source
of calcium it takes like 12 steps to be
able to be converted into your body so
it's just like taking eating rocks it's
cheap and of course you have all these
synthetic um elements Malto dextrin
synthetic vitamins there's a huge
difference in nature between real
vitamin complexes and these synthetic
petroleum
fractionated paper weight type products
so and I often times say read the other
ingredients too of almost any vitamin
they're usually packed in soybean oil
corn oil and defeat the whole purpose of
taking supplements in the crazy so
that's my viewpoint on one of days so
Bobby thank you for evaluating all these
great Foods if you're not already signed
up on his channel go to his channel put
his link down below and I really really
really want your uh feedback on the
content and what foods you might be
interested in doing further videos
comment down below tell me what you guys
think